gouvernement de transition a appris avec
une profonde indignation
des propos tenus par le président de la
république française
emmanuel macron lors de sa tournée en
guinée-bissau le 28 juillet 2022 en
effet au cours de sa conférence de
presse le chef de l'état français a
réitéré des accusations et launay en
affirmant que les autorités maliennes
entretient des relations avec un groupe
paramilitaire
sans jamais apporter de preuves malgré
les démentis des autorités de la
transition
pire dans ses propos il a évoqué
l'exercice de la violence pour les
autorités moyenne
ciblant une ethnie spécifiques de notre
nation le gouvernement de la transition
condamne avec la dernière rigueur ces
propos un noeud
diffamatoires du président français et
prend à témoin l'opinion nationale et
internationale
sur ces accusations graves qui sont de
nature à susciter la haine ethnique et à
porter atteinte au vivre ensemble à la
cohésion ainsi que l'harmonie entre les
moyens la france qui a toujours oeuvré à
la division et à la partition de notre
pays est mal placée pour donner des
leçons aux mots ni le gouvernement de la
transition exige du président macro
d'abandonner définitivement
sa posture néocolonial
paternaliste et condescendante pour
comprendre que nul ne peut aimer le mali
mieux que le malien eux mêmes